[音楽]
分
た
ああああああ
ん
皆さん
こちらの写真を見てい
なにこれこちらの写真が何に見えますか
これを見て何を想像しますかん
ただの洗ったでしょうか
それともゴミでしょうか
僕は少しちょっと視点を変えて何がこれこういうものでネジないかな
面白いものは作れないかなと日々考えものづくりをしていますそしてそれが僕の趣味
です
僕は
スターズでアルバイトをしているのですがこれはエスターずにあるものだけで作った
作文です
捨てられたり俳壇になったりまた必要とされなくなったものを使ってこのかチングを
作りました
世界学校から食べる来られるベストにこのた[ __ ]を提供してやっ実際にやってもらう
ことで面白い
何かこれ面白いなコメントをもらったりその中で起こる
会話を楽しみました
当社僕はこのパチンコを作るという発想があったわけでもなく
パチンコを作りたいというそんな強い思いだったわけでもありませんです
でも何か5杯ゼロスだって女が作りたいなと思ってこのパチンもつけたんです
じゃ目ですけど go to sleep とがちょっと将来も入っています
こちら
すっごいシンプルなんですけど str スプーン余ってたいっ
机です
官軍に言われた作るちょっと声なんで半分には頭からか分からないんですけどそれを
使って僕は
ローラゴウラムレイニーさんがよくやるような
これを作りましたん
それに人の友達80kg 友達んこれに乗ってもらって遊んでもらったんですけど
実際に壊れることなく強度もしっかりしています
よいしょもないものなんですけどどちらも
僕はこれを使って何か新しい発見をしたりっていうよりも
ものづくりというところの話ではなくて今か今日お話しすることはプリクラー子の話
ちょっとなきゃ言ってるのかわからねーなぶりくら市なんだ
ぶりっこ官1人は菅野があるかもしれませんがそうではありません
りこらーずの定義は
ありあわせの道具材料を用いてものを作ること
そしてウィプロ味をする人のことを振り頃
このように置きます
フランス人の文化人類学者レヴィストロースの長所
野生の思考の中でこのようにいます
駄文煽れして青いしてメールログイン
我 baby a
大彗星奥入瀬6分
早まっている
持ち合わせ
すなわちその時その時限られた道具や材料を用いて
ものを作ること何かをすること
それがゲームのルールである急ぎである
このゲームというのはブリコラージュものづくりをする中での世界観
つまりず僕たちがぐらいのせいかさの生活環境の確保を指します
僕がからくりプラージュと出会ったのは今から約2年前
僕が降らずに留学していたときのことです
1番目で教えるのが北で
その横にいるのがフランス人の頭差
今可愛いん
てこのお父さんはい意見を開いて見えるんですが実は近いエンジニアです
朝鮮普段戦 ps を基に次回や足んぱなその部品を作ったり
ものづくりのプロフェッショナル
でもお父さん
そういうプロフェッショナルの音画面も待ちながら実はすごい不思議な面を持っていた
んです
コレなにしてるか分かりますか
実はお父さん家の外や中を歩き回って
の廃材ペットボトル缶家のな便が使えないものとか捨てられているもの
それを探して物作りをしていました
そのときにこのお父さんのホームが
全然なんか納得いかなかったでしわけがわからなかったのでそれ何しているのを聞き
ました
その時にお父さんから帰ってきた言葉が
ぶりくらいだったのです
そしてお父さんこう続けました
2つぴ今やの中にいろんなものがあるけれどもそれらは
買って渡しているこれを繰り返しをしている
それで僕たちが普段しててるものであったり
はちょっと壊れたもうそれ
コンマ必要なんじゃないか
でも僕たちはそれらに目を向けず何か新しいもの
何かまたというものはもう入りしたりとかあるのでそれはもういいしてるしまう
その考えがちょっと古いんじゃないか
それはちょっと視点を変えることで微細プロもできるし新しいクリエイティブの
アイディア
小山ソリオつながる
お父さんこういう報告にみましたん
名草ブリコラージュという音の響きが何かと可愛らしさがあった面白さがあったり
パソの発想がちょっと面白いなと思ったので今回はブリコラージュについて勉強する
ことにしました
移住と言っても聞いているわけですね
恵比寿とバスは少々野生の思考の中で
振り子ラーズと妻させるためにエンジニアリングを用いています
エンジニアリングとは現在の科学的思考
そして科学的思考は設計図を用います
設計図を用いてものづくりをするのです
できたものは常にパンピ
例えばこの女3回の解除アイサイトで当たり
僕たちが普段触るもの見るものそして誰でもそれらのものは水程度の家で常に完璧な
状態になります
だからて覚える必要はないん
それぐらいで
これこれ
レヴィストロースのえろグルバーズは1011子
願い社会で会社からのことを指します
や性的嗜好は設計図を用いません
あり合わせのもの手持ちのもの自分のまわりのものを即興いたして作る
なので完璧にはなりません
完璧にはならないからそこになるがをつけます
そしてまた完璧じゃないから次のものを作ってまた付け足す
そういう風にして僕たちの先祖まあ祖先は文化を築いてきました
これが発展というものです
そのリポライブ
でも日本に快適で
この発想する時代ないのかなうりこらーじゃないのかなという天宮
ができるのはこれを続けていくうちに僕の身の回り
意外とぷりぽらんぷりプラウドする人そしてプリパラいるんだということに気づきまし
た
そしてレヴィストロースの利用ありあわせでつくるを応用して
あり合わせ進化する
こういう仮説を立てで丘フィールドワークをすることになりました
殺さ生
僕ラバーが永続の食前とを切ら vip をしている様子です
長くの多くの新聞さんたちがやっている行動だと思うのですが家に帰ってきた子ども
たちがお腹を空かしてこれを食べてあれを食べたい
あまりは
意味のわからない注文していきます
それに対してお母さんは大
ある食材ある調味料そしてお母さんの腕を使って時間的制約を受けながらも子どもの
要求に応えるしかないんですそれを読む者であっん
方から空港生の時に
夢帰ってきてお腹わずかしておりました
おばあさんステーキ食べたいん
そんなあるわけもないん
ずっと的にお母さんは
他部門
番号とっております
それではん
こんにゃくしているができます
いやーになります
と思いながら食べてみるとそれがとってもおいしいで
web している前田な紅葉謎に他なりません
このこんにゃくが頭部になることもあるし
また違うものになることもあります
その時に僕の考えが少し変わります
正義は必ず市のリンクではないそしてありあわせのもので作ったものは意外な活動を
目指して面白いものを作るなところは美味しいなと思っ
僕の僕の実家の二階のベランダを公示した時に出た
会いたいです
廃材といっても少しグループの木材なのですがみなさんならこれどうしますか
していますか
それともちょっと他にはからって容赦2月とってもらえますか
僕の父は側しませんでした
これを開いてキープして
家の西側の選択も結ばこれを作ったんです
芦ノ湖のクオリティをすごいというのもあるんですけどもっと注目すべきは設計図が
ない中でこれらの物を作った
この沿っ票制そしてこのスキルです
よ僕たちは料理もこの料理であったり
作り物であったり
お互いに共通していることは設計図を用いずありアートなもので作ることです
者なんだよ
勘ぐりコラージュをプロに振りこらーず振りプラージュた続けて熱く語ってるん
でしょうか
何でこれが今の世の中に必要なのでしょう
僕たちの今の世の中って
もので者情報で溢れていますよね
友達が目の前にいてもスマートフォンを触ったり何か
ものを作ろうとしても常に google であってやがるであったりいろんなもので
検索をかけます
そうすることで僕たちがもともと持っていた
野性的そういう感覚です関西であったり
店またその後館近く
視覚聴覚味覚嗅覚にそして昇格
僕たちはそういう感覚が鈍ってきていると言われています
をなっていません
今日は僕他に来るときに電車を使ったんですけどほとんどの人がスマホを書いてみてい
ました
横に友達がいるのに上司がいるのにその会話を試しまず
妻籠の端で何かをしてたんです
それでちょっと
いいんだけども何か寂しいよさん
そのすることで僕たちは頭を使って
体を動かして小倉で何かを感じ取る
そういうことをそういう感覚が薄れてきたんじゃないかなというふうにほか桜です
でも
おいこれ
その間たですぶりくらいになったらこういう野性的な感覚は居やしない
僕たちの社会を持って良くなると思うんです
今とても便利な世の中になりましたその10時にあの方のおかげですごい
いろんな物が増えて帯等の社会を豊かになりました
ただそこに僕たちが失った子どもと思っている感覚で半耐寒性磁性
それらを付け加えることで
さらに大きなそして豊かな社会になるのではないか
そうか考えたんです
ブリコラージュにこれから出してみたいですか
うりこらーになってみたいですか
っていうのも僕達それぞれはぐりこらーなので
ただそれを失っているだけ
でもその感性感覚を取り戻すのはすごく簡単です
ではどうやって実践していたらいいでしょう
プラセスは3つ
まず設計図を持っていないそして自分の今の状況
自分の手持ちのもの周りののロンアップすること
次に想像です
例えばコクランはぁがやったように冷蔵庫を開けてそのものと会話をする
触るに酔う感じる
そして頭を働かせで想像する
そして3つ目創作
星形成金なんかで作るのは難しいですかあーでもないこーでもないと言いながら失敗し
ながら
年まで繰り返してまた新しいものをつけてまだ失敗してまだ分割
4創作することがぶりプラスの web ラジオしてブルーカラーになれる
ぽいるのです
僕が今日お話ししたことは
社会に大きな影響を与えるイノベーションではなく
生活の小さなところにをするイノベーション
僕たちが普段をしまっているものであったり気づかないところ
それてもともと send 挑戦がある方が持っていたのでもそういうものを取り戻す
ことができます
もう一度この数字を見てください
これをゴミと思うそれともから来たと思う
たださてを変えで何か新しいものができないかな
何か社会を変えてある
そういうないだろうか悪いかな
こういうなものを考えてください
では今日家に帰って冷蔵庫を開けてみてもいいですし
例えばレシートをもらったレシートをしているのであるかそれを聞いてメモにするとか
小さなことでいいです
そういうことを繰り返して
僕たちはプリプロそしてエンジンには
そして家だから者からいる
いきましょう
ありがとうございました
[拍手]